- Here's my wonderful donkey, Thistle.
Hello, you wanna come out?
And she tells me, “Of course, am I stupid?”
“Freedom,” she's saying, “Oh,
it's a (beep)ing about
time you got here, yeah.”
There we are, a donkey that's weird.
It was quite magical, talking to animals,
'cause they're sharing
their experiences with you,
they're giving you a
perspective into their world.
Gonna go and see the others?
Yep, okay.
I do converse with my pets
on a day to day basis,
and we chat about the most unusual things.
I've had the lectures
on American politics.
You come closer?
- [Camera Person] What's she saying?
- Just, yum yum.
Thistle's not sure how to behave now.
He talks about crime shows, of all things.
If we have the TV on,
she'll be outside the door watching it.
This is from her position, it's like,
they've actually got a
really good storyline,
but they've got to have strong characters,
to actually bring it together.
Probably the thing that
I learned as a child,
is that you do get bombarded
with a lot of information
from the animals.
It just comes in all the time.
You go outside, the
birds are talking to you.
You sit on the grass, the
worms are talking to you.
I'm getting a little
bit queasy here cause,
I didn't realize, I'd actually
taken some spiderwebs down.
I don't think he's lost
far, he's just in the house.
Was going to have a Skype session
with my client in America,
‘cause she's got a new kitten,
but the kitten's gone missing.
Hi.
- [Client] I can't find him.
- Tell me where you've looked.
- [Client] All over our house.
- I would just keep talking to him,
and see if we can get him to
come out, and show himself.
- [Client] Will he come to Finn?
- [Faye] He will.
- [Client] Finn, kitty,
kitty, kitty, kitty, Finn?
Can he hear us right now?
- No.
To communicate with any animal,
they don't have to be present with me,
so what I'm trying to do is just
to get Finn to share about his day.
This is just random impressions
that have come through.
It is my game.
I will be found.
When you're a child,
the power of the
imagination is so powerful.
I mean, what is reality
and what's not reality?
I remember a few
childhood experiences with
animals would be telling me
things and I would tell my mum,
and she would say, "Animals
don't talk, it's cartoons."
Hello!
- [Client] Hi, I found Finn.
Isn't he gorgeous?
- He's actually just so relieved.
He's enjoyed all the dramatics over him.
- You're wonderful with what you do.
I feel more connected with the animals,
it brings joy and also
brings a little sorrow,
and a little pain.
But, I don't know what I would
do, if I didn't have you.